[Applause]
[Applause]
one of the basic truths of The Human
Condition
is that people love to float
and there's no better place to float
than here at the Dead Sea in Israel
[Music]
where without any effort at all large
mammals can achieve buoyancy
there's some ritual involved to doing
this place the right way
you need to fall into some mud
lather up and then relax with a good
read
sorry to do that to your white shirt
Jack you handsome devil
Israel has many wonderful sides
and this is one of its finest
Arabs Jews tourists and TV hosts all
come here
can't help but float together for a
while
and laugh
it's unfettered
or at least less fettered Joy
[Music]
[Music]
it would be nice if this story could
remain so simple
but it can't
to come to Israel is to witness the
fierce tensions that Loom over this
country firsthand
it's spy balloons floating by highways
it's walled off and fenced in Arab
cities
and tourist spots turn quiet
due to the stabbings and random acts of
violence that have become so prevalent
over the past two years
episode of hello world
I'll dig into how the constant threat of
War
gave birth to the Israeli technology
industry foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
and how Israel evolved into a technology
Giant
one with thousands upon thousands of
cutting-edge startups
my journey will find me in Jerusalem
controlling an iPad with my eyes
at the Gaza Strip checking out Iron Dome
up close everything you see here can be
moved out in a matter of hours
and in Nazareth I'll meet with a man
that wants to make sure no one gets left
behind in Israel's race to innovate
foreign
[Applause]
Valley may be home to some of the
biggest Tech Giants in the world but
it's being challenged like never before
crazy Tech Geniuses have popped up all
over the planet making things that will
blow your mind
my name is Ashley Vance I'm an author
and journalist and I'm on a quest to
find the most Innovative Tech creations
and meet the beautiful freaks behind
them hello world
[Music]
the Israeli military dominates much of
this country's culture
[Music]
at 18 years of age men and women head
off for two to three years of required
service
kids who would be trying to locate the
best kegger are sleeping through class
in the United States
find themselves here dealing with the
most intense of situations
young soldiers in the Israeli Defense
Forces or IDF also learn to use some of
the most advanced military technology
around
to see how the IDF has given Israel a
unique Tech Edge I decided to check it
out up close
to see the Iron Dome
[Music]
I've traveled to Ashkelon
the coastal city just south of Tel Aviv
that nudges up against the Gaza Strip
what you were seeing here right now is
the launcher
each launcher has 20 missiles on it
see the red light flashing which means
it's armed and ready
[Music]
here one of the dozen or so Iron Dome
batteries sits at the ready to intercept
missiles and provide Israel with a type
of shield from aerial attacks from the
Iron Dome Commander Lieutenant Colonel
Iran Cohen oversees its operation is
this as close as we get or do we get uh
this is as close as we get
[Music]
just three years and about 200 million
dollars to develop this defense system
it relies on a radar that instantly
detects when a missile has been fired
algorithms quickly try to determine what
type of projectile is in the air and
whether it's heading for a populated or
strategic area
if so Iron Dome launches a missile of
its own
said that Iron Dome has taken down more
than one thousand missiles since it
turned on in 2011.
with a 90 success rate
question the accuracy of these
at least clear though
the algorithms capable of directing
projectiles while performing a
cost-benefit analysis on human life are
among the most advanced in the world
this network of launchers is highly
mobile and constantly on the move
this site like many is temporary
everything you see here can be moved out
in a matter of hours
and we move around a lot to make sure
nobody knows where we are all the time
unless you live here it's difficult to
imagine just how much this technology
has transformed the lives of ordinary
Israelis I can tell you from my own
personal experience sitting in my own
house and seeing Rockets fired towards
my house and operating this incredible
system and succeeding but they aren't
doing when you see your house that
you're protecting and your family and
your friends and your soldiers it's a
sense of
great uh sense of pride
for many Palestinians Iron Dome means
something else
it's just the most visible part of an
expansive Israeli security apparatus
that includes drones
checkpoints
an Espionage technology
those tools have been put to immediate
use in the West Bank Gaza and throughout
Israel
terrorist bombings have declined
missiles have met their match
but lower Tech forms of protest like
stabbings are now on the rise
[Music]
what's been remarkable is the speed at
which young Israelis take these types of
high-tech tools
and then privatize them once they leave
the Army
be it peacetime or War
Israeli Innovations pop up throughout
the world
foreign
[Applause]
startups of Tel Aviv come to life here
in the city's vibrant neighborhoods
they feed off the city's energy
and the employees have a chance to
escape their cubicles and live a little
I came here to meet one of the people
that shaped the Israeli startup
lifestyle
[ __ ] Kramer served in the IDF almost
25 years ago and his first company
checkpoint invented the freaking
firewall
we always had the startup box so we
always talked about stuff that we will
do afterwards and it was always around
startups
like a lot of Israel's tackle it [ __ ]
got his start with unit 8200 a top
branch of the IDF group 8200 right is
this is this famous part of the IDF that
I guess equivalent to NSA in the United
States was like the bedok of everything
else that I've done afterwards was it 22
23 year old that was the head of a unit
you know of 20 people
you know very high responsibility you
know I was you know making decisions in
millions of dollars and
the IDF functions sort of like a
never-ending networking event the first
question at a cocktail party is what
unit you served in for members of unit
8200 these ties have led to Israel
dominating the market for security
software and Hardware what makes Israel
so well suited to to startups and
Technology there's always an infusion of
new Talent
form the IDF and the infusion of talent
you've got the recipe for a successful
startup Nation yeah [ __ ] has invested
in dozens of Israeli companies
to see the extreme end of what the IDF
can Inspire I've gone to herzelia
small Beach town and Tech Hub that
brushes right up against Tel Aviv
it's here that a company called
spacepharma has set out to make some
Interstellar drugs
[Music]
if Humanity would like to move out of
Earth they must learn the microgravity
conditions in order to survive on the
way to Mars and to other places Florida
CEO Yosi Yamin used to head up the IDF
satellite program then he and his
comrades hit on a big possibly
profitable idea
they assembled some space software and
science experts and set to work trying
to make life easier on astronauts we cut
the middlemen the astronaut is not a
scientist you need to survive you need
to eat you need to train you need to
sleep
he cannot do too much science
space Pharma has built a shoebox size
laboratory that will hitch rides into
orbit on Rockets from companies like
SpaceX the goal is to shrink down
state-of-the-art scientific equipment
and automate how it runs experiments
this would allow a great deal more
science to take place on the
International Space Station
so we're going to go in the labs okay
thank you for the booties you're very
welcome
so it's a pretty small bio lab but the
equipment's big and this you can't bring
to space so the whole idea of what we're
trying to do and what we're really going
to look at is how we take this equipment
and bring it down to the small scale
a typical laboratory has
refrigerator-sized machines microscopes
pipettes and a host of liquids and
chemicals
it's a very manual messy process that's
tough enough to pull off here on Earth
we just looked at all that large
equipment this is what we fitted in
one on the ISS has already led to the
development of new drugs and insights
about organisms
molecules floating about freely in
Solutions can behave more naturally than
when they're smeared flat on a petri
dish ever
if dominated by this lens of gravity
what goes up must come down we remove
that lens of gravity and we learn
something new
spacepharma wants to use its machines to
let companies and researchers conduct
dozens of different kinds of experiments
and to see what space can teach us
to pull myself out of the clouds and
learn more about Israel's startup
culture I went for a walk on the beach
back in Tel Aviv with another local Tech
Legend
thank you very much armed with a law
degree and an MBA ADI sopher Tani had
led a number of young companies and
helped spur on Israel's technology
economy 50s now she runs Facebook's
Israel operations
today we have we have something like 5
300 startups in Israel by the way
the country in the world that
would except the US yes okay it's
1 400 new startups in 2015. 1400 new
startups
[Music]
women must serve alongside man in the
military here
he wants hope to fly Jets but because of
the gender restrictions at the time
she ended up evaluating who could become
a pilot
he sees the time in the Air Force as
crucial to her career what's the
uniqueness of the female experience in
Israel because of the military service
it must have some long-term effects yeah
I absolutely think he does women in
Israel
um probably start their career life with
more confidence with the feeling that
they also can but now we're done in
Israel in terms of women taking part no
we are not and and I think that in
Israel we are probably because of the
military because of startup Nation
because of the culture I think that we
are probably
closer to achieve that but we are
definitely still not there
foreign
that I go Revel in Tel aviv's famous
nightlife
Tel Aviv stands out as one of the great
surprises of my travels people head out
late here often starting dinner at 9 00
PM
the bartenders look for any excuse to do
shots with their patrons and their
patrons or at least this Patron look for
any excuse to oblige the Beach
The Old City the boardwalk Joy rides
this is a wondrous place that feels at
times as if it exists within its own
bubble separate from the rest of the
country
[Music]
from the Cosmopolitan Coast
I climbed the winding Mountain Road to
Jerusalem
[Music]
Tel Aviv may be the Beating Heart of the
Israeli Tech world but most Jews
consider Jerusalem to be the country's
soul
foreign
you know what they say about the soul
[Music]
the most basic thing of human
communication is is eye contact
by the device seeing you you get a whole
nother world of interaction the window
to the soul the window exactly the
window to the solar the window to the
brain
look around look to the right look to
the left UT Kempinski is the co-founder
and CEO of umove based here in Jerusalem
the company has developed a way to
replace eye tracking gear that usually
costs tens of thousands of dollars with
algorithms that can run on an iPad or
smartphone it's a little disorienting at
first to try and play a video game just
by moving your head
so you see head movement eye movement
Iris movement blinks and then and then
an analysis of that
Kempinski hopes the technology will give
us New Rapid insights into conditions
like concussions
so this is like when they Shine the
white light that you have to follow I
mean you see doctors doing that right
exactly and then based on the score we
can tell if I have a concussion and I
don't you don't have one I don't have a
concussion
[Music]
kampinski thinks that these hard science
applications with real world uses
distinguish Israel's Tech scene
especially for Jerusalem startups people
are looking for you know real deep Tech
I can't say I'm you know making an app
for taking pictures of food you have to
give a you know a real explanation to
your uh Jewish grandmother about what
what is that for
foreign
[Music]
it's not that far at all from where we
were earlier today
there's a sniper up in the window who's
guarding against a lot of the recent
stabbings that have been going on
Jerusalem's trying to turn into a
Technology city and this is the reality
of how these businesses have to come to
life in this type of environment
thank you
the moment you step into Jerusalem it's
clear that the city carries with it the
weight of thousands of years of History
everyone in the Middle East and by
extension the world has their eyes fixed
here
on Alexa mosque
on the Wailing Wall
on the spot where it's believed Jesus
was crucified
this is a small spot of land with
outsized global importance
under heavy guard
carved into my Newt slices and fortified
with walls
those barriers went up to curb violence
based on Ancient disputes
seen another way they've become
blockades
that hold back modern opportunity
[Music]
foreign North
from Jerusalem to Nazareth
the largest Arab Enclave in Israel a
place with a laid-back Vibe and a very
specific flavor
we can see a 10 or 15 places just for
shawarma
so because of that I call it the
Shawarma Valley sure you have the
Silicon Valley we have the Shawarma
Valley and we are at the middle of the
Shawarma Valley that's fari Sudan he
opened Israel's first Arab Tech
accelerator and he knows everyone in
town
Arabs do not have to serve in the
military and lack the tech connections
supplied by the IDF
Fadi is set to work trying to fix this
and to help Arab Engineers benefit from
Israel's Tech boom
in a controversial move he's linking
them up with the tech Moguls who have
come out of the idf's unit 8200
spooky security and Espionage folks
anyone is going out of state 200
first thing is thinking about this to
make a startup
the eight undergraduates have a special
NGO that help them
at our community it's not so popular to
have stuff up because it's a new
industry it's very risky
is a rebel okay he was the only Arab in
his class at the technion Israel's Elite
Technical University
oh inside of this building he shepherded
dozens of like-minded Engineers
they're building software consumer
services and Hardware in an effort to
make sure that the Arab speaking world
has the latest and greatest technology I
think if we can be part of the ecosystem
in Tel Aviv and to be part of the
startup Mission we can raise the
standard of life of the Arab Community
here because Israel is known as this
startup Nation but it's left out a big
chunk of people so exactly there's two
communities the Arabs and the Jewish
Orthodox the government now is putting
some money to find a ways how to engage
them with a startup Nation here because
they believe that if we are not part of
that the startup Nation will be somehow
slowed here and it cannot continue to be
the second place after the Silicon
Valley
[Music]
a handful of his companies have already
taken off and made Headway in billion
dollar Industries but it's proven tough
for them to find investment dollars
there's a clear bias against Arab
companies and many of their backers have
opted to remain anonymous or to funnel
their Investments through offshore
accounts
but Fadi remains optimistic I hope in
the coming years maybe we have big
success stories let's say the first
unicorn startup from the Arab community
may be here in Israel so this may began
attract more and more entrepreneurs to
be part of that and like other
businessmen to be part of this industry
foreign
[Music]
came to an end
it's understandable that tourists have
made fewer visits here in recent months
that the markets have grown quieter
and the mood in the streets more tense
this place can seem daunting from afar
to visit Israel though is to experience
the extraordinary foreign
so many parts of our nature
Joy
conflict
conformity
and Imagination
swirl around together in confounding and
inspiring ways
I'm not sure that anyone will really
ever make sense of all this
[Music]
but it's spectacular to witness and feel
even if just for a short while
[Music]
as for my next stop well that would be
Iceland
home of alien landscapes
an astonishing amount of fish
and space Warlords
[Music]